ranspach décortiquer les résultats avec
gaspard flamand le duel s'annonce est
serrée entre la majorité présidentielle
et l'alliance de la gauche les deux
formations arrive presque à égalité à
elles deux elles cumulent la moitié des
votes exprimés et ne sont séparés que de
vingt-et-une mille voix du côté de
lannux on considère ce premier tour
comme réussie c'est un excellent
résultat qui transforme j'allais dire ce
que laissait en réussite sur ce que nous
avons eu affaire avec la nuque mais
j'allais dire aussi c'est le plus
mauvais résultat d'un président de la
république on peut les tours des
législatives voilà jamais un présent et
fait moins de 30 2% les deux camps en
maintenant une semaine pour mobiliser
avant le second tour ait tenté de
l'imiter l'abstention qui a atteint un
nouveau record 52 5% dépassant celle de
2017 selon les projections le camp
macron garde quand même l' avantage il
obtiendrait entre 255 et 295 siège quand
les députés de la nuque ce sont eux
estimés entre 150 et 190 ce qui en
ferait le principal bloc d'opposition
les républicains et leurs alliés peuvent
espérer entre 50 et 80 sièges le rn
espère lui former un groupe
parlementaire pour la première fois
depuis 1986 maintenant le camp
présidentiel souhaite une seule chose
conserver sa majorité le parti de la
majorité les partis de la majorité
présentielle sont en tête sont
rassemblés et que nous sommes en bonne
position dont 421 une circonscription
sur 577 est un signal fort celui de
faire en sorte que la majorité
présidentielle sortante est au niveau
national et sortent globalement en tête
dans l'essentiel des circonscriptions de
notre pays hier cinq députés ont été
élus dès le premier tour 4-1 soumis et
un issu de la majorité présidentielle
du côté des ministres les 15 qui se sont
engagés dans cette élection accèdent au
second tour s'il était amené à perdre
ils devront quitter le gouvernement
on analyse les résultats de ce premier
tour des élections législatives avec mes
invités catherine tricot bonjour
bienvenue vous êtes directrice de la
rédaction de la revue regards qui titre
son tout dernier numéro sur justement la
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale voilà où de compter sur la
chance ça ça peut le faire on croise les
doigts jean-philippe dubrulle bonjour
vous êtes directeur d'études institut
ifop bienvenue jean garrigues
l'historien président du comité
d'histoire parlementaire hauteur de la
tentation du sauveur histoire d'une
passion française 7 aux éditions payot
et matthieu croissandeau éditorialiste
politique bonsoir messieurs bienvenue à
vous évidemment question toute simple
toute bête catherine tricot pour
commencer quel gagnant ou la gagnante du
premier tour
aller la nuque quand même oui je pense
hier qu'on avait quand même une gauche
je me souviens que vous avez montré
notre une en janvier où on disait la
gauche grand remplacer c'est à dire
qu'on avait une gauche qui était non
seulement divisé mais qui était à thoune
qui ne sentons on n'entendait pas dans
des débats publics les positions de la
gauche qui était complètement recouverte
par eric zemmour est là elle a non
seulement elle arrive au coude à coude
avec le parti des bagnoles macron mais
elle a réussi à imposer à remettre dans
le jeu ses compositions et elle a dont
environ 400 circonscription des
candidats qui sont extrêmement déterminé
qu'ils sont jeunes qui sont à lons et
qu'ils sont déterminés à gagner donc je
pense que l a fait un bon résultat et je
pense qu'elle en fera un bond dans une
semaine on verra bien évidemment jean
philippe dubrulle on va voir pendant que
vous me répondez les
les résultats officiels du ministère de
l'intérieur je le rappelle avec
effectivement ensemble et la nuque dans
un mouchoir de poche je le disais 25 75
contre 25 66 et le rn qui arrive à 18 60
8 comment vous analysez là je vous pose
une question sur le score d'ensemble la
coalition de la coalition de la majorité
présidentielle comment vous l'analysez
c'est un camouflet je vais oser ce mot
là parce que il faut dire que depuis que
les élections législatives se déroulent
dans la foulée de l'élection
présidentielle et donc bénéficier de
l'effet de souffle de l'élection du
président élu donc je pense que si on
remonte à jacques chirac les
législatives après la présidentielle
c'est plus sain couvoir +13 points pour
le camp du président par rapport au
score de celui ci au premier tour
l'élection présidentielle or là on aime
emmanuel macron café 28% au premier tour
l'élection présidentielle et aux
législatives
son camp fait moins que ça donc c'est
non seulement il n'y a pas eu cet effet
souffle +5 à +13 points mais même c'est
un recul donc en soi
c'est un coach qui a raté par la
majorité si vous avez goûté à ça bien
évidemment le résultat extrêmement
serrée avec celui qui ceux qui s'érigent
en opposant principal jean luc mélenchon
et la nuque vous avez une double
avertissement pour la majorité actuelle
jean garrigues effectivement si on si on
regarde l'histoire c'est peut-être aussi
nié au fait que emmanuel macron est le
seul à avoir réussi à être réélu hors
cohabitation c'est ça que ça nous dit
c'est ça nous dit ça nous parle de la
sueur personnalisation de la vie
politique aujourd'hui et notamment 30
rennais est survalorisé par emmanuel
macron lui-même le fait qu'il n'ait pas
suscité un véritable mouvement autour de
lui ça se traduit par papa par ce score
par ce recul qui est incontestable y at
il un succès de la gauche un succès de
la nuque à cette élection là je suis un
petit peu plus circonspect parce que
l'on constate que finalement l'addition
des voix des socialistes de l efi des
communistes et des écologistes en 2017
l'émeute est à peu près 26% qu'il qui
sont ce vraiment un focus sur la nuit
rappelons aussi qu on pourrait
considérer parce que tout est affaire de
focales dans cette de point de vue dans
cette affaire pourrait considérer que le
principal gagnant de ces élections c'est
l'horreur rassemblement national c'est
le seul qui a véritablement gagné six
points qui a confirmé d'une certaine
manière même si le score évidemment est
bien plus faible que celui à la
présidentielle mais à caen confirmé pour
la première fois sont avancés à
l'élection présidentielle et qui va
avoir pour la première fois depuis
fameux groupe jean marie le pen de 86
qui va avoir un groupe dont on sait pas
la composition mais mais qui sera un
groupe substantielle donc oui c'est il
ya plusieurs manières de voir les choses
pour moi le problème dans tout ça c'est
que je suis pas sûr que ça soit le
parlementarisme tels que moi je le
conçois qui est qu'ils soient et qu'ils
soient gagnants parce que ça a été hyper
personnalisés c'est ça a été le mari
donc de ge en éliminant les cédantes
législatives on voyait toujours quand
même le portrait du président du chef de
parti à ouidah du député enfin du temps
dit ding il ya une longue campagne du
président c'est ça c'était un choix que
le président a fait le choix de
l'abstention considérant que l'électorat
de la nuque baisse est un électorat
prédisposé à l'abstention et que donc
forcément pour atténuer l'effet du ps il
fallait de il fallait de l'abstention
est d'ailleurs finalement saab a si mal
fonctionné parce que je le répète il n'y
a pas de progrès de la gauche à ces
élections il ya un progrès symbolique
une dynamique un coup prestidigitation
de de jean luc mélenchon mais ça n'est
pas véritablement un progrès de la
gauche c'est pari risqué quand même de
la part des mots c'est une faute
tactique c'était que le mozart des
finances n'est pas forcément mozart de
la politique on l'a bien vu ça il ya eu
un choix de jouer la montre d'abord pour
essayer de rapprocher le plus possible
la composition et de la faim l' annonce
et la composition du gouvernement de
l'échéance électorale qui s'est passé
pendant trois semaine ya rien eu quand
je dis rien c'est rien et madame macro
ont fait quelques déplacements après son
élection et puis un très grand vide dans
lequel évidemment se sont engouffrés
tous les partisans du président à la
fois deux annoncé leur ambition pour
jean luc mélenchon elysées -
prémunissent ensuite de réaliser cet
accord sur lequel beau qu'un peu de gens
parié un kopeck et puis de dérouler une
plate forme programmatique dont on pense
ce qu'on veut mais en tout cas ils ont
eu le temps de se mettre en ordre et
d'occuper le terrain et d'occuper
l'espace médiatique et quand ensuite le
gouvernement a été nommé il se trouve
qu'ils étaient dans deux périodes de
reiser il se trouve que comme il n'avait
rien à dire parce qu'il ne pouvait pas
dire grand chose et qui n'avait pas non
plus grand chose dans les tuyaux il faut
bien le dire le fameux paquet pouvoir
d'achat on s'aperçoit que ça c'était
finalement après pour des raisons de
règles du jeu parlementaire après
l'élection législative
on s'aperçoit que le chèque alimentaire
ben voilà ça fait un an et demi qu'ils
bossent qui avait rien dedans ils se
sont retrouvés assez dépourvu sur tout
sujet à toutes les attaques extérieures
possible à toutes les faits extérieurs
pour slim doux damien abad où le stade
de france on qu'ils ont été sur la
défensive et il n'y a pas eu non plus
dans le choix d'elisabeth bornes qui est
une personnalité tout à fait honorable
et respectable mais qui n'est pas un
poids lourd politique il n'y a pas eu au
gouvernement quelqu'un qui puisse
entraîner la majorité dans la danse et
donc résultat des courses cette espèce
de campagne escamoté de campagne tardive
volontaire de la part des stratèges
de l'elysée retombe comme un soufflet
parce que même si nous ne sommes qu'au
premier tour et même si le deuxième tour
peut parfois avoir une correction ou une
amplification ça dépend donc il faudra
attendre pour voir si si si une majorité
relative ou absolue en tout cas à
l'heure des comptes au premier tour ben
c'est plutôt une banane parce que des
métiers des personnalités quand même de
la main chroniques qui sont en déroute
il ya des anciens ministres qui sont
battus il ya des menaces sur certains
membres du gouvernement et puis un score
on l'a dit qui est quand même médiocre
et le cas jean michel blanquer quand
même à enlever matic assez emblématique
de ce qui s'est passé hier soir voulait
intervenir oui cette stratégie de la
campagne fantomatique dans marche elle
peut aussi s'expliquer par ce qui s'est
passé lors de la présidentielle
repartons quelques mois en arrière on a
un emmanuel macron qui est dans les
intentions de vote début janvier environ
25% il restera relativement stable
jusqu'à l'éclatement de la guerre en
ukraine là ça montre réflexe du drapeau
est en fait emmanuel macron ne commence
à baisser qu'à un mot précis c'est le
jour où il annonce à aubervilliers lors
d'une conférence de presse finalement
ses premières pistes de programmes et
notamment la retraite à 65 ans autrement
dit il était resté totalement
insaisissables pour les oppositions tant
qu'il ne disait rien et dès qu'il dit
quelque chose il a laissé une accroche
possible ce qui a commencé à le faire
baisser or sans contrecarrer sa victoire
finale donc peut-être que les stratèges
dans marche sont dit tiens nous allons
le faire conjurer ce précédent là ne pas
offrir de prise à nos oppositions mais
comme dirait l'autre ça n'a pas marché
mais est ce que vous diriez qu'il a il
n'a pas anticipé ce qui s'est passé au
soir du second tour qui peut-être nous a
surpris des uns et les autres d'ailleurs
si on se souvient comment l'analysez
c'est à dire que le le l'entrée
de jean luc mélenchon dans le match
l'absence totale d'état de grâce
peut-être même un petit manque de
fair-play républicain de la part de jean
luc mélenchon et de marine le pen en
tout cas voilà c'était c'était
surprenant par rapport à ce qu'on avait
vécu lors des précédentes victoires
présidentielles on peut imaginer que les
mâles bacon la part anticipé sa wii avec
ce oui il est absolument aucun état de
grâce parce que tout le monde savait qui
était manuel mâcon quelle était sa
stratégie sa politique est donc
évidemment tout le monde était en ordre
de marche mois ce qui a été surprenant
évidemment c'est que jean luc mélenchon
est réussie sur la base du rapport de
force incroyable qu'il avait a su
imposer à gauche à réunir toute la
gauche lui même qui quelques années
quelques mois auparavant ne prononcez
pas le mot gauche et
vitupérer lui l'alliance sauf à la
tentative de primaires de la gauche la
soupe aux logos etc il a réussi sur la
bête son score de 22 % et tous les
autres à moins de 5 alors imposé sans sa
loi et à se présenter et c'est comme ça
maintenant qu'il est vécu il faut se
rendre compte du renversement c'est que
dans la gauche jean jean jaurès la
figure de changerait c'est à dire le
grand unificateur du camp socialiste au
début du 20e siècle ben aujourd'hui
c'est jean luc mélenchon c'est à dire
celui qui va réussir à réunir tout le
monde alors ghana qui font un peu grise
mine mais alors moi ça a fonctionné
alors on va l'écouter tout de suite
genre jean luc mélenchon avant de donner
la parole à mathieu pour analyser cette
cette victoire de la nu parce qu'elle
n'est pas quand même un petit peu en
trompe-l'oeil donc jean luc mélenchon
hier soir il prend la parole alors alors
au moment où il prend la parole je le
rappelle plusieurs instituts de sondages
placent la nuque en tête on écoute la
vérité que le parti présidentiel
au terme du premier tour est battu
et défait
pour la 1re fois de la vème république
un président nouvellement élu ne
parvient pas à réunir une majorité à
l'élection législative qui suivent
j'appelle notre peuple
a déferlé dimanche prochain
mathieu le succès de la nuque peut-il
sauver la gauche c'est la question à
laquelle vous vous pouvez nous répondit
à me crier victoire en le voyant qu'ils
sont mais là même un peu les pinceaux
dans l'histoire puisqu'il est que ça y
est j'ai eu un précédent quand même avec
avec france la réélection de françois
mitterrand et michel rocard ils ont créé
victoire j'ai sans doute un peu trop tôt
mais enfin ça faisait tellement
longtemps que on enterrait la gauche que
on peut comprendre qu'ils aient sa voix
d'or bonheur au lendemain de ce premier
tour des législatives catherineau disait
la nuque et les partis qui la composent
sont assurément les grands gagnants de
cette première manche même s'il s'agit
selon certains aspects quand même d'une
d'une victoire en trompe l'oeil dans la
colonne succès qu'est ce qu'on veut
mettre l'union de la gauche on a parlé
d'abord avec cet accord électoral qui
était loin d'être acquis loin d'être
évident et qui est du jamais vu depuis
les années 70 parce qu'on dit souvent
les périodes l'épisode de la gauche
plurielle n'y avait pas d'accord
électoral la faille avait chacun partait
sont saisis selon sous ses propres
couleurs la fierté retrouvée ensuite ce
qui n'est pas rien pour un électeur de
gauche des soirées d'élection avec avec
une victoire devenait aussi rares que
victoire au français à roland garros
janvier c'est ça permet de relever la
tête ça a l'air idiot il génère sais pas
non plus rien de relever le drapeau dans
la colonne succès toujours la gauche
s'apprête même à envoyer trois fois plus
de députés qu'elle en a aujourd'hui au
palais bourbon avec notamment catherine
et les allusions à l'heure de nouveaux
visages de nouveaux espoirs de la gauche
et puis il était quand même le troisième
homme de la présidentielle il devient le
premier opposant donc tout ça à tout
seigneur tout honneur ce succès il faut
d'abord le mettre au crédit de jean luc
mélenchon qui avait l'intention de
l'intuition pardon de tenter ce double
coup de poker d'abord réclamé qu'on élit
ce premier ministre sans lui même se
présenter à l'élection contre toute
logique institutionnelle et puis surtout
rassembler autour de lui on le disait
aussi tout à l'heure d'anciens camarades
avec qui les relations étaient plutôt
fraîches voire glaciales
au soir de sa vie politique c'est donc
une gauche revigorée que l'aigle le
leader a soumis aux générations
suivantes fait mieux leur avait été de
recommander au soir du premier tour ça
va pas être évident donc ça c'est pour
la colonne succès aidant le côté trompe
l'oeil alors bel trompe l'oeil c'est de
croire que ce succès déjà une victoire
écrasante pour la suite d'abord parce
qu'en raison de l'abstention nom de ses
bons scores sont quand même à
relativiser même s'il faut bien le
reconnaître les insoumis qui contestait
la légitimité des manades macro souvenez
le président très mal et lui disait jean
luc mélenchon à cause de même là ils ont
été bien discret sur ce plan hier on n'a
pas entendu les candidats télé fille
clémentine autain ou raquel garrido qui
était sur les plateaux télé rappeler que
leur score était de ce point de vue
assez médiocres aussi puisque la
première a recueilli 14 % des inscrits
et la seconde 13% donc pour montrer
qu'il faut quand même relativiser
c'était énorme effet de victoire il ya
quand même une abstention massive aux
facteurs à prendre en compte c'est le
rapport de force électoral j'en use
allusion tout à l'heure en pourcentage
de voix là du ps ou la nuque je ne sais
pas a fait à peine mieux que les scores
additionnés du ps du pcf 2 les filles et
des écolos en 2017 c'était 25,7 contre
25 49 à l'époque peer se prends tu
prétends du raz-de-marée de gauche et
quand même inférieur de près de quatre
points au score cumulé de jean luc
mélenchon yannick jadot fabien roussel
et anne hidalgo il ya un mois donc elle
est à la fois une dynamique de
rassemblement mais aussi de la perte en
ligne le total gauche quand même pour
que ça nous dise une idée est
historiquement bas dans l'histoire de la
vème république il est plus bas que lors
de la déroute de 1993 mais surtout le
dernier trompe l'oeil et non des
moindres c'est que le second tour risque
d'être plus compliqué pour la nuit ps
parce que faire l'union au premier tour
mais ça c'est évidemment les réserves de
voix au second tour et puis le
positionnement de radicalité de rupture
de jean luc mélenchon c'est évidemment
moins assembleur qu'un positionnement
centriste - - - hennebont disruptif
voilà j'allais dire jean luc mélenchon
ne risque donc pas de voir tellement la
couleur de matignon mais la seule
consolation pour ses défenseurs c'est
que ce succès même limité de la nuque ps
va avoir deux effets d'abord de
compliquer sérieusement la vie du
gouvernement en particulier si celui-ci
ne réussit pas à décrocher une majorité
absolue mais une majorité relative et
puis ensuite il craint en effet kiss
cool si je vais dire le deuxième c'est
que ça rit suscite le bon vieux clivage
droite gauche après cinq années de
tentative d'effacement parce que c'est
facile pour emmanuel macron de dire
qu'il est à la fois de droite et de
gauche ont tjrs avait 17 députés a
soumis et 25 ps aujourd'hui il ne pourra
plus le lire avec un groupe de près de
200 parlementaires de gauche la nuque
mais ce ne donc ou ne coupera donc
peut-être pas les ailes du président
mais elle aura rendu unijambiste ça
c'est sûr jean garrigues
l'usure d'optique vous êtes d'accord
avec cette idée vous avez commencé à
l'évoquer pts à leur jeu même vous
détailler cette victoire de la nuit ce
ce qu'est ce qui est à mon sens
salutaire mais on en reparlera sans
doute c'est que ce le paysage qu'est
qu'on va à voir se dessiner au lendemain
du second tour va quand même beaucoup
plus ressembler aux rapports des trois
grandes forces politiques que la
présidentielle nous avait dessiné déjà
que ce que n'avait jusqu'à présent hier
que le le le jce d ation de la vème
république alors est ce que c'est un
trompe-l'oeil weeds d'une certaine
manière on le voit bien mais les
chiffres ont été donnés vers la la la
y'a pas un raz-de-marée de du ps mais
sur le plan symbolique et c'est
essentiel en politique sur le plan
symbolique on voit bien qu'une dynamique
est née
le problème qu'il faut se poser mais
c'est le même problème à droite c'est
que moi je ne parle jamais de gauche je
parle des gauches et que cette alliance
nubes je le maintiens ce sont des
gauches et des gauches très différentes
ont des gauches qui vont chacune avoir
un groupe parlementaire je m'en réjouis
d'ailleurs parce que cette c'est ce
morcellement cette fragmentation non
seulement va provoquer de vraies
discussions à l'intérieur de cette
coalition qui en fait est une coalition
électorale mais elle va susciter des
débats et elle va et elle va permettre à
chacun d'exprimer ses sensibilités et
plus largement d'ailleurs on va
retrouver la même chose dans la dans la
famille de deux des manuels macron c'est
à dire que avec renaissance y aura deux
partenaires 1 qui seront nécessaires
pour avoir une majorité au mieux absolue
peut-être seulement relatif ce sera
horizons et et le modem et il va falloir
là aussi négocier discuter c'est à dire
que mécaniquement le parlement il va
retrouver sa fonction de délibération de
discussion de contrôle aussi c'est à
dire que sur le long terme sur le très
long terme pour moi c'est une très bonne
nouvelle sérieux catherine tricot c'est
intéressant parce qu'effectivement on
peut dire que la coalition
la solidité de cette ou deux c'est
d'ailleurs coalition suis d'accord avec
jean ça vaut aussi pour ensemble
elle va être mise à l'épreuve à
l'assemblée la solidité de la coalition
du coût d'ensemble il y avait quelque
chose qui était quand même très fragile
c'était les partis tels qu'ils étaient
devenus c'est à dire que c'est parti
rassemblé des militants qui ne pensait
plus grand chose en commun et en fait
cette alliance de danube est finalement
elle a produit un effet de clarification
à l'intérieur des partis c'est à dire
que le parti socialiste est redevenu
s'est repositionnée serre est axée sur
sa gauche dire qu'il y avait quand même
un doute donc vous dit il n'y a pas tant
de sensibilité différente je pense qu'il
ya des sensibilités différentes à
l'intérieur de la du ps mais le parti
socialiste il ya une clarification qui
s'est opérée il ya une clarification qui
est en cours de
bail à une clarification recours à
l'intérieur d'europe écologie les verts
pardon 4e mais il avait déjà changé ils
sont benoît hamon socialiste ben oui
sauf que benoît hamon il a été soutenu
par l'ensemble du parti socialiste donc
on n'a vu qu'une partie soutient
finalement emmanuel macron d'ailleurs
dès le soir de l'élection d' emmanuel
macron donc en fait cette clarification
est maintenant elle est au bout elle
n'est pas complètement terminée parce
qu'il aura congrès du parti socialiste
on verra ce que feront les amis de
carole delga et de françois hollande
donc ce groupe là on ne sait pas tout à
fait s'il va rester ou s'il va créer un
autre parti mais en tout cas l'idée que
le parti socialiste est ferré ancré à
gauche c'est olivier faure qui le dit
très bien servi maintenant on réentend
le parti socialiste on leur ait
identifié à la gauche donc y aura des
différences à l'intérieur de la nuque
vous avez tout à fait raison mais il ya
une clarification dans des partis de
gauche qui à mon avis va leur permettre
de retrouver aussi du tonus et de la
part de la contribution au débat
politique jean philippe du roule aussi
est-ce que vous retrouvez finalement les
nuances les dons par legendary où
finalement le le
le décalage
idéologique du parti socialiste de
l'ancien parti socialiste comme le comme
le dit catherine tricot quand vous
analysez les raisons du vote d'hier au
sein de l'électorat du global mans
l'électorat de gauche finalement a saisi
la balle au bond parce que la demande
d'une union de la gauche elle est quand
même ancien et persistant depuis un
certain nombre mais est ce que pour
autant c'est un électorat homogène ça
peut être la façon de poser la question
d'une façon un peu plus simple de ma
part pour l'instant il l'est pour
l'instant il est on verra quand il
faudra comment dire répartir l'héritage
une fois l'accession à l'assemblée fait
mais pour l'instant c'est ce que je dis
il y avait un tel désir d'union une
telle désespérance dans la personne n'a
cité se presser dans l'âme et après la
droite la plus bête du monde certains
pouvaient maudire la gauche la plus bête
du monde qui avancent en ordre dispersé
à l'élection présidentielle donc
finalement une union tant attendu la
grande partie du peuple de gauche se dit
on y va même si voilà de sa de là on
peut lire on peut voir des réactions des
jeunes notamment qui dit or j'ai envie
de voter nul mais mon candidat dans ma
circonscription il ps sait pas trop
c'est pas trop mon oui c'est un peu et
c'est ce que disait match auteur il ne
cotait un peu fierté retrouvée aussi
quoi voilà il ya il ya toujours des
obédiences différentes mais là il y
avait une occasion de courir d'enfoncer
les portes de l'assemblée cette occasion
est saisie en rien une partie de
l'électorat de gauche qui a voté pour
des dissidents comme on les appelait
pour des candidats socialistes qui se
présentaient par exemple contre des
camps et adultes mais tout ça est restée
extrêmement marginale au final le peuple
de gauche saisit la balle au bond de
cette union mais il ya quand même une
partie du peuple de gauche qui a voté
macron enfin oui pour les candidats se
sentent orphelins aujourd'hui c'était
évident
un énorme électeurs orphelins étaient
l'électorat social démocrate parce qu'il
ne peut pas se reconnaître dans la nuque
parce que la nuit pas une autre approche
qui est aussi historique dans l'histoire
la gauche française n'en paraît mieux
point qu'est la gauche révolutionnaire
la gauche radicale liée pour changer le
système si je caricature la gauche
sociale démocrate qui était pour
corriger le système elle ne peut pas ne
veut pas changer le système donc on ne
peut pas se reconnaître dans cette
famille là et puis il ne peut pas elle
ne pourra plus haut tout cas très
difficilement se reconnaître dans dans
la famille macro nien d'une certaine
façon si celui-ci mécaniquement hanche à
droite alors il a déjà donné beaucoup de
gages du froide dans son mollet
quinquennat mais la même politiquement
mécaniquement avec le jeu parlementaire
s'il n'avait qu'une majorité relative
pas trouvé ses alliés de circonstance à
gauche il va les trouver à droite c'est
les républicains qui vont être du coup
les faiseurs de roi ou les faiseurs de
lois plus tôt donc j'arrive à quelque
chose qui se déporte vers la droite dans
la macro ni et du coup tout cette espèce
de 2,2 d'électorat qui était quand même
une composante sociologique majeures de
l'échec électoral les sociaux démocrates
vont se retrouver orphelins ou
contraints de changer son évolution à ce
qu'il n'a pas fait son bad godesberg
individuel ce dernier n'a pas fait sa
transformation ce que je veux dire c'est
que on n'a pas vu finalement les
électeurs de françois hollande qui était
parti chez les bagnoles macron presque a
sur 2 des électeurs de françois hollande
a voté pour emmanuel macron en
2007 ils ne sont pas revenus à gauche
ces terres qui ont fait 7 cette
évolution politique elle a été fait je
veux bien se dire que les mêmes bornes
dit je viens de la gauche oui non mais
d'accord mais c'est une vieille histoire
qui vient de la gauche avant mais
aujourd'hui tu n'es plus de gauche je
veux dire
c'est que je suis jaloux non mais moi je
pense que je pense qui d'ailleurs si je
parle pas d'elisabeth bord on a un peu
son nom par e mail mais globalement il
me semble quand même que mais c'est ce
que c'était dit c'est que il ya quand
même un électorat effectivement on peut
le qualifier de social-démocrate voire
même social libéral qui se réclament des
valeurs de gauche il faut notamment ceux
des valeurs sociétales et c est cet
électorat là ne peut pas se reconnaître
dans le danube est peut-être mais pas
dans la france insoumise dans la danse
gauche radicale qui expriment les
différences et donc que ça les
précédents d'union de la gauche elle se
faisait autour d'un parti de réformes
que tu es un parti social démocrate et
le parti socialiste là vous avez quelque
chose quand même de très brutal tra de
traits de très clivant de très
transgressif et analyser de très
autoritaire avec le jean luc mélenchon
des analystes qui ont décortiqué qui ont
mis côte à côte programme de la nuit
baisse et le programme commun mais
programme commun était beaucoup plus
radical que le programme de la nouvelle
et le temps des années 70 en tout cas
parti communiste qu'on avait un parti
communiste n'a pas rallié surnage avec
un parti socialiste dirigé par françois
mitterrand qui a été élu président de la
république a connu un tournant de la
rigueur 285 que je vais vous dire ce que
je veux dire c'est que dire
qu'aujourd'hui la nuque baisse c'est
l'extrême gauche on me semblent être une
une lecture qui n'est pas exact c'est un
changement paradigme c'est
bien entendu par rapport à des gens qui
pensaient qu'il fallait passer des
compromis en politique que c'est pas
forcément des compromissions parlera
parader à une école de pensée sociale
démocrate ou ont discuté des textes on
débattait il y avait des courants
d'opinion il y avait des gens qui
étaient d'accord puisse été tranchée par
un vote c'est pas du tout cas à la
france un sur dix est pas de vote donc
je crois qu'il ya une question
d'organisation et certains
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec vous
mais ce n'est pas cette exagéré de dire
que c'est un programme radical et
révolutionnaire je pense que franchement
c'est plutôt un programme keynésien et
qui par contre a intégré la question
écologique au coeur de celui de son
alors
justement glas de la faisabilité de ce
programme et ça c'est encore autre chose
mais c'est vrai qu'un égout thème de
débat cette semaine sur le programme
économique et notamment la fiscalité le
type d'intervention et de deux manières
de concevoir la politique que jean luc
mélenchon a introduit dans le débat
aujourd'hui avec ses petites phrases
avec sa manière très oui disruptive la
police itunes par exemple ça c'est
quelque chose qui est nouveau dans la en
tout cas qu'on connaissait plutôt dans
l'extrême gauche française s'était pas
quelque chose qui est elle qui faisait
le tronc commun comme ça des alliances
de du passé enfin imagine pas lyonnais
le jeu spa ou france ou même françois
mitterrand dire la police tue d'envoyer
là il ya quelqu'un quelque chose qui est
qui a déporté complètement la kz2 de la
gauche de la même manière qu'à droite
lac s'est déporté vers rassemblement
national on retrouve la même chose à
gauche d'une certaine manière et c'est
assez c'est assez logique parce que les
intérêts de de crise de la démocratie de
même de crise de civilisation
on va vers défaire des solutions
extrêmes la protestation elle se
retrouve dans des solutions extrêmes et
moi je pense qu'il reste un espace pour
un autre type de gauche de plus paul
social est prise je récuse l'idée de son
des solutions extrêmes je pense sont des
solutions qui sont un moment donné j'en
ai eu besoin a dit pour que ça change il
faut que tout change donc effectivement
oui mais non c'est pas extrêmes ça veut
dire c'est une une loutre logique ce que
jean luc mélenchon cherche à défendre
c'est une autre façon de prendre tout à
l'heure on s'amusait entre nous en
disant alors leur vie saine dans ça ne
marche pas des gens nous sachions déjà
juste avant que l'émission démarre c'est
que new line mélenchon prend acte que
l'auris allemand ne marche pas et
cherche une autre manière de mathieu
montcourt et son parcours sur qu'ils
s'en aillent tous il faut prendre au jeu
les puissants ses plans mais si c'est
cette gauche là mais non mais non mais
non mais franchement là je sais ce que
c'est c'est plus sage en prison ils ont
échangé mais c'était le bruit et la
fureur le 80 ans est construit en tout
cas politiquement dans son parcours et
son discours avec ça qu'ils s'en aillent
tous en
1971 au moment de la création du congrès
du parti socialiste du congrès d'epinay
dit que celui qui n'est pas anti
capitaliste celui qui n'est pas anti
kabyle il n'a pas sa place au parti
socialiste jeudi allez je vous fait
partie du débat par une question pour
jean luc mélenchon fait le même parcours
que françois mitterrand où il savait
bien alors je boucle cette partie des
bas avec une question pour jean philippe
du boulès que les électeurs de la nuque
ont le sentiment de voter extrême gauche
non clairement non simplement on va
faire une réponse très claire et c'est
pour ça que quand vous lier c'est une
question de dax qui se déporte petit à
petit et tout cela est aussi alimentée
par la perception d'une impuissance du
politique à chaque élection quand on
demande on interroge les
abstentionnistes mais pourquoi vous
n'êtes pas allés voter et la raison qui
ressort le plus c'est ça ne sert à rien
les gens pour qui on me demande de voter
sont impuissants ils ne changeront rien
à la société rien à la vie rien ma vie
et donc dans ce contexte là où vous ne
croyez absolument pas dans la puissance
politique et bien pour motiver les gens
à aller voter il faut il faut envoyer du
bois
forcément que de part et d'autre en plus
avec un centre qui est apparu comme par
magie etc irak a pris une place énorme
forcément que et à droite et à gauche
pour motiver les troupes il faut
proposer des choses qui descriptif alors
on ouvre un autre chapitre dans ce débat
qui rejoint évidemment de diffusion
qu'on va aussi parler d'eux la nuit pet
de ce bras de fer
dans la perspective du second tour avec
la majorité présidentielle
gérez bien une semaine peut nous
rejoindre en plateau bonsoir jérémy
venait installez-vous il ya évidemment
ce débat cette polémique autour des
résultats de la nuque expliquez-nous ce
qui se passe mais en fait ils hier soir
plusieurs estimations données la nuque à
égalité voire même en tête du scrutin
mais selon les chiffres officiels
publiés par le ministère de l'intérieur
c'est bien le mouvement de la majorité
présidentielle ensemble qui devance la
nuque avec un peu plus de 21 mille voix
des chiffres qui ont fait réagir dans la
nuit manuel bompard directeur de la
campagne de jean luc mélenchon est
candidat nuque dans les bouches du rhône
qui dénonce lui une manipulation de
gérald darmanin et revendique près de
300 mille voix d'avancé pour l'union de
la gauche et ce matin clémentine autain
qui est candidate à céret à sa
réélection en seine-saint-denis ne
décolérait pas est accusée elle aussi le
ministre de l'intérieur en écoute en art
effectivement une interrogation plus que
forte plus que forte qui laisse à penser
que monsieur darmanin ministère de
l'intérieur ont voulu quelque part
mettre en avant la macro ni donc oui si
monsieur darmanin a voulu traficoter les
scores c'est dans un but qui est un but
de donner l'impression que le match est
plié alors comment on peut expliquer
cette différence entre les chiffres
officiels ministère de l'intérieur et
ceux avancés par la nuque et bien en
fait la nuit pas sûr que plus de
quarante quatre mille voix de trois
candidats investis n'ont pas été
comptabilisés en ardèche en haute
garonne et en meurthe et moselle mais la
différence s'explique aussi par les
résultats de l'outre-mer ou des
candidats proches de la nuque non pas
l'étiquette nul car l'accord électoral
entre insoumis socialistes écologistes
et communistes ne concerne en fait que
la france métropolitaine par exemple à
la réunion jean hugues ratenon actuel
député insoumis et karine le bon qui a
défendu le programme de jean luc
mélenchon tous les deux arrivés en tête
il hier dans leur circonscription se
sont présentés sous la nuance est bien
divers gauche alors le ministère de
l'intérieur n'a donc pas compter ses
voix pour la nuque
alors que la coalition de gauche
affirment soutenir ses candidats pour le
second tour et les ajoutent elles dans
son total de voix un calcul critiqué ce
matin par christophe castaner on peut
l'écouter se trouve que il parle de
jaune qu'ils soutiennent maintenant
alors qu'ils ne soutenaient pas il ya
deux jours et ils voudraient les
comptabiliser parce qu'il les soutient
maintenant dans tout ça n'est pas très
sérieux les services du ministère nateur
que je connais bien fond avec les
préfets au plus près du terrain en
fonction des remontées des déclarations
des candidats ne cherchons pas à
rajouter du complot à la culture
complotistes que l'on connaît dans la
france insoumise et ce débat nous
rappelle la polémique qui précédait ce
premier tour autour de la reconnaissance
de la nuance nuque oui rappelez-vous
thomas le ministère de l'intérieur
refusé de reconnaître cette nuance en
fait pour les élections législatives les
partis politiques de gauche avaient
alors saisi le juge des référés du
conseil d'état et la juridiction avait
donné raison à la nuque en début de
semaine dernière alors aujourd'hui qu'en
est il est bien dans un communiqué
publié cet après-midi la france
insoumise dénonce cette situation
mais ce matin sur notre antenne eric
coquerel candidats en seine-saint-denis
l'a assuré il n'y aura cette fois pas de
recours au conseil d'état pour contester
les résultats du premier tour merci
jérémy voilà pour pour ce récit d'un
bras de fer et d'une polémique catherine
tricot elle et
ça mérite pas qu'on y passe dix minutes
dans le débat ou et en même temps elle
et ça ne m'aurait aidé porté par jean
luc mélenchon et ses lieutenants donc
comment vous l'amabilité vous cette
plage la question c'est qui est qui sort
en tête mais juste ça alors là on voit
qu'on joue à 20 mille voix dont toute
façon on peut dire que c'est quand même
à peu près à égalité et que l'enjeu
c'est qui fat donnée la dynamique pour
le deuxième tour c'est ça la vraie
question mais pour créer cette dynamique
de second tour va être en tête c'est pas
rien et je vois que ce soir le monde
fait également ses propres comptes et
explique ses comptes et met la nuque
également en tête parce qu'il intègre
comme le demande la france a soumises et
la nu c'est-à-dire intègre les candidats
d'outre-mer et trois autres candidats
qui n'a pas été comptés parmi certains
c'est dire qu'en fait cette question il
ya le ministère de l'intérieur compte
sur sa position france a soumises compte
sur sa position le monde à bondues côté
mais moi je pense que le vrai c'est peu
c'est juste une question symbolique qui
a son importance pour la campagne c'est
tout simple quand il y avait quatre
parties la droite la gauche à la base
elle s'est même pas une plan b c'est oui
je sais pas c'était une boutade mais pas
que parce que c'est totalement vrai
puisque voilà cette affaire des nuances
politiques puissent alterne donc le
ministère de l'intérieur les préfectures
lorsque les candidats déposent leur
candidature
éthique est finalement ces candidats
donc déjà en amour il ya quelques
semaines le mystère matters a fait
passer une circulaire en listant
finalement les nuances quel être adopté
leurs compositions déjà à l'époque
c'était ça paraissait bizarre mais bon
je vais aller très vite parce qu'on
pourrait pas personnellement je pourrais
passer deux heures sur le sujet on va
éviter en tout cas l'important dans ce
sens à retenir c'est que ce qu'a fait le
ministère de l'intérieur à cette
élection à ces élections législatives en
termes de qualification politique est au
minimum très lacunaire à tel point que
nous avons dû ainsi du sondage certes
mais d'autres médias comme le monde par
exemple ont dû à la première publication
des candidatures par le ministère dont
tout refaire à la main puisqu'on ne
savais pas qu'ils étaient nus baisse on
ne pouvait même pas les retrouver en
additionnant les socialistes les
insoumis des communistes et les verts
puisque les verts étaient eux-mêmes
dilué dans un paquet écologistes où il y
avait les animalistes
la cap 21 la 8c donc c'était impossible
de s'y retrouver dans cette soupe il a
fallu tout faire à la main c'est pour ça
qu'on a des décomptes différents donc un
mauvais point pour le ministère qui n'a
pas fait les choses de manière claire
mais aussi un mauvais point et là je me
mets du point de vue des gens qui ont dû
chercher à la main les informations vers
les parties nous ont pas beaucoup aidé
ainsi l'on excepte le parti pirate le
parti animalistes des modèles du genre
qui ont fait des tableaux extrêmement
claires permettant de retrouver leur
candidat ni la nuque ni la majorité ni
aucune coalition on a mis clairement une
vraie liste consolidée définitive en
disant voilà qui sont nos candidats
personne tant que c'était pas facile à
faire je cite un exemple qui cité un
réseau lignac l'ardèche sortants qui se
représentaient qu est un socialiste qui
est désigné par le ps comme candidat de
la nuque qui dit moi la nuque c'est pas
moi je suis pas un insoumis à tel point
que les insoumis font une pétition pour
deux candidats donc voilà c'est il fait
partie aujourd'hui des personnalités
sont demandeurs et inclure dans le
listing des victoires de la nuit et les
tickets tenue profitable mais c'est
compliqué la politique c'est compliqué
d'étiqueter les gens en fonction oui et
puis parce qu'on dit il et de la
dissidence parce que c'est un tout jeune
c'est une solution aussi j'en ai un
longue histoire mais toutes manières de
du flou artistique des candidatures il
ya ça a toujours existé voilà ce qui
m'étonne quand même c'est que la nuque
et je pense qu'ils ont eu raison fait un
recours au conseil d'état pour obtenir
d'être inventorié comme nous alors
pourquoi ne font-ils pas là un recours
au conseil d'état pour obtenir que soit
quantifie qu'on comptait comptabiliser
ces voies outre-mer ils ont mis à faire
non oui mais s'il avait mieux à faire
alors pour parler du fond des programmes
alors je veux servir à ça les 80
milliards ça les intéresse plus que ça
un milliard c'est ce qu'a soulevées sur
luc mélenchon hier soir quand il dit
emmanuel macron après un engagement sur
les 80 milliards qui représente le
budget de l'éducation nationale et
budget de la police rassemblés et qui
promet d'économiser donc c'est une
promesse à l'europe bon une promesse
alors je vais vous laisser sa
démonstration pour dire que ça
m'étonnait parce que c'est quand même ça
c'est pas le gouvernement s'est pas
darmanin qui a sorti cette affaire
ccnucc baisse et les sorties en profite
malgré tout avec un petit parfum de
complotisme de brutalisation des débats
que ce que je déteste ça c'est le jeu de
jean-luc mélenchon et et et de ses amis
là ils ont traficoter les élections qu'à
un petit soupçon quand même sur le
ministre de l'intérieur qui serait pas
très honnête
et puis ils ne vont pas jusqu'au bout de
la démarche donc je me dis qui a quand
même tout petit parfum la de
victimisation cette bonne guerre mais je
pense que effectivement comme vous le
dites le débat mérite mieux que
seulement deux allées on a beaucoup
parlé de la nuque je voudrais maintenant
que on ouvre un chapitre consacré au
rassemblement national avec bon eh
ce score qui concerne marine le pen 53
9% des voix dans sa circonscription du
pas de calais elle n'est pas pour autant
d'ores et déjà député parce qu'il n'y a
pas eu à cette participation en rappel
que cette règle a valu pour de nombreux
candidats
hier la candidate du rassemblement
national à l'élection présidentielle qui
a remercié ses électeurs hier avant
d'espérer un groupe important à
l'assemblée on écoute je tiens à
exprimer ma plus sincère gratitude à
tous les électeurs nationaux qui dès le
premier tour ont fait confiance au
candidat du rassemblement national ces
remerciements s'adressent bien sûr
d'abord aux électeurs de la 11e
circonscription du pas-de-calais qui
m'ont placé à 55% des voix le second
tour nous offre la possibilité d'envoyer
un groupe très important de députés
patriotes dans la nouvelle assemblée
nationale nous pouvons en effet espérer
nombre de députés pour faire valoir avec
coeur et conviction vos idées vos
valeurs et vos intérêts comme pour
défendre votre pouvoir d'achat ou votre
sécurité jean film d'uwe boll quelles
sont les caractéristiques du vote
rassemblement national ya notamment
peut-être sur l'ancrage local est ce que
le parti est resté fort dans ses fiefs
est ce que c'est ce qu'on peut dire pour
commencer ou est ce que finalement il ya
un élargissement ce contrat ce qui est
sûr c'est que les places fortes du front
du rassemblement national aujourd'hui
sont restés les mêmes principalement
dans le nord on a beaucoup glosé lors la
présidentielle sur l'extrême droite du
nord l'ex traînera du sud l'une plutôt
marine le pen l'une plutôt eric zemmour
alors bon eric zemmour est escamoté de
campagne législative lui-même déjà et
sont partis également mais si on revient
sur marine le pen et leur assemblée
nationale oui les positions locales
finalement ont été conservés sont même
prolongées et finalement ce défunt pour
marine le pen n'était qu'une formalité
dans son fief d'hénin beaumont avec tout
comment dire tous tous ces élus locaux
de ce coin là donc des positions
confirmés mais aussi voilà de la
progression dans certains espaces qui
sont finalement les espaces dans
lesquels marine le pen à l'échelle
nationale prospère également les zones
plus isolées les zones plus paupérisées
bref celles qui sont l'antithèse du
récit macro nist de la mondialisation
heureuse et de la start-up bichonne s'il
fallait caricature et mathieu ce qui est
quand même intéressant c'est que si on
analyse la campagne de marine le pen on
pourrait on a parlé de discrétion qui
chaleur ou de retard à l'allumage on
peut employer exactement les mêmes les
mêmes expressions pour pour marine le
pen et donc je me dis en creux que si
elle avait fait campagne si elle avait
affiché un objectif beaucoup plus
ambitieux dès le départ elle sera
peut-être encore enfin son parti sera
peut-être encore plus aujourd'hui c'est
possible une vraie interrogation qui est
partagé y compris par des cadres du rpt
assemblée nationale contours et un
moment que la campagne promet une drôle
de tournure parce que marine le pen
avait pris quelques jours pour se
reposer puis a eu du mal à revenir à la
coller sur ses affiches visage de jordan
bardella a goûté du sien donc aux
escales une passation de pouvoir une
transmission de témoin de tant de jordan
bardella du n'était même pas candidat à
la députation vu qu'il est eurodéputé
qu'il n'entend pas en bouger et et
marine le pen c'est quand même quelqu'un
qui était deux fois qualifié au second
tour de la présidentielle qui avait fait
42 % des suffrages au second tour il ya
deux mois et donc oui on aurait pu
imaginer qu'au delà des verrous
institutionnels et du jeu de
qualification qui est difficile il ya
toujours des servies le front national
opération nationale aux législatives
elle puisse impulse est quelque chose de
de mieux de plus fort d'autant qu'elle
l'avait fait pendant la campagne
présidentielle sur les questions de
pouvoir d'achat
résistant missiles eric zemmour
reprenant des couleurs arrivant à se
qualifier elle aurait pu en chant
enclencher quelque chose elle ne l'a pas
fait elle peut avoir des regrets
aujourd'hui juste sur une chose quand on
regarde les estimations alors ça ne vaut
pas ce que c'était que des projections
des projections des instituts de sondage
au lendemain de la présidentielle pour
certains je sais pas si c'était le cas
du vôtre mais données entre 35 et 80
parlementaires au rassemblement national
pour certains aujourd'hui on est quand
même sur des étiages qui sont beaucoup
plus serrées 35e faux souvenirs 1986 le
record du d'union nationale a et c'était
à lacets sarcelles et c'était à la
proportionnelle donc voilà peut-être si
elle avait enclenché la seconde elle en
aurait pu avant d'avoir beaucoup plus
mais de toute façon et quand même une
victoire c'est une institutionnalisation
du rassemblement national c'est une
respectabilisation supplémentaires entre
guillemets d'avoir un groupe
parlementaire
ce qui signifie temps de parole ce qui
signifie droit d'initiative qui signifie
tout un certain nombre de prérogatives
et pour leur assemblée nationale ça sera
une forme de victoire oui mais par
catherine tricot qu on va l'analyser
finalement ce score du rassemblement
national et peut-être aussi un peu la
même question cette campagne bizarre de
marine le pen voit deux petites choses
c'est que j'ai noté qu'elle sait
nationaliser c'est à dire qu'en fait si
vous regardez la carte que sort le monde
ce soir avec l'endroit où il en fait il
ya des petites taches marron un peu
partout ce que je veux dire qu'on n'est
plus simplement dans le quart nord-est
et le pourtour méditerranéen ça s'est
généralisée est en effet les quartiers
la france plus profond du rural mais
d'autres endroits comme la gironde par
exemple c'est à dire la france dé gilet
jaune aussi géré qui n'est pas que la
france rurale c'est la france des gilet
jaune se retrouve largement dans le vote
marine le pen et donc ça sent quand on
conforte sa place et elle se destine à
l'iss c'est une vraie question de la
deuxième chose c'est que j'ai entendu
hier guillaume pelletier remettre sur le
tapis la question qui avait poussé eric
zemmour de l'union des droites et à mon
avis c'est finalement ce qu'a fait jean
luc mélenchon rassemblant les frères
ennemis de la gauche la question de
savoir comment va se passer est-ce que
marine le pen eric zemmour et l ère qui
n'a pas défini son positionnement c'est
à mon sens qui a vraiment trois courants
et on sait bien que ceux çi évoqués
n'ont pas dit leur dernier mot donc
cette question de s constitue un bloc de
droite très à droite nationaliste est
une question qui à mon avis reste devant
et jordan bardella peut-être intéressé
par une telle proposition je voudrais
aborder un dernier thème dans ce débat
qui concerne à la fois marine le pen est
en creux jean luc mélenchon jean
garrigues jean luc mélenchon a fait le
choix que moi je ne m'explique toujours
pas de ne pas se présenter oui donc de
se priver de la tribune que notamment la
présence d'un d'un groupe apportez à
l'assemblée marine le pen elle va a
priori on verra s'il passe les 15
députés en bénéficier oui c'est d'autant
plus étrange que jean luc mélenchon créé
des conditions d'une dynamique et
réussit à gauche donc très logiquement
il aurait dû être le fer de lance au
parlement à moins qu'il ait misé de
manière quasi sûr sur sa présence à
matignon mais c'était un pari quand même
très très risqué je ne pense pas qu'il
qu'il avait pu le faire donc on très
naturellement on l'imaginait en leaders
de cette opposition au parlement et il y
aurait vraie vérité ablement là une
tribune qui est de par ses talents en
plus de d'orateur et tribunicien serait
serait idéal et tandis que marine le pen
qui a l'art en revanche j'avais les
moyens d'essayer de faire une campagne
gagnante ça a été dit elle a laissé un
peu tombé mais mais malgré tout comme si
elle avait comme dire ça intégrer le
fait que de toute manière le
rassemblement national n'ayant aucun
allié potentiel ayant décidé de
siphonner reconquête qui était réussie
ayant essayé d'anesthésié reconquête et
n'ayant donc aucun potentiel de
d'alliance au second tour aurait de
toute manière un
groupe marginal en tout cas secondaires
mais c'est vrai que c'est c'est partir
un peu dans un cas comme dans l'autre
c'est un petit peu étrange on en arrive
pas à comprendre véritablement les
ressorts en tout cas moi je les
comprends pas un mot sur jean luc
mélenchon absent de l'assemblée moi je
pense que jean luc mélenchon prépare la
suite
seulement passer la main il a annoncé
qu'il voulait prendre la tête du centre
du think tank qui est proche de la
france insoumise et je pense que ce
qu'on s'est dit tout à l'heure c'est à
dire que la pensée de la transformation
sociale il a posé des éléments qui sont
plutôt je disais tout à l'heure de type
néo keynésien il sait bien qu'il est
pour nous de la réflexion et que je
pense que ce qu'il va faire et surtout
qu'à l'assemblée de la sison 120 150
députés hills aux 220 240 300
collaborateurs qui vont pouvoir mettre
au travail pour pouvoir penser organisé
cette réflexion ce programme pour la
suite et je pense que c'est ça que près
par jean luc mélenchon n'a pas dix ans
un héros mais il va mettre ses efforts
sur le travail intellectuel ce qui
l'intéresse profondément tous les c'est
dommage c'est dommage parce que sa fille
on va manquer à l'assemblée à la fois
parce que c'est un orateur un tribun
c'est une figure inspirante de la vie
politique qu'on l'aimé ou qu'on le
déteste jean luc mélenchon c'est
quelqu'un à qui on peut vouloir
ressembler où on peut vouloir battre aux
élections enfin c'est quelqu'un qui ne
laisse personne neutre c'est dommage
parce qu'eux aussi ils avaient pour le
coup une vraie pensée articulé qu'il
aurait pu développer à l'assemblée il va
devenir un homme politique né lui un
homme politique de conférence de presse
et je trouve que sans doute mérité mieux
que que ça merci à tous les trois
d'avoir participé à ce premier débat